this is a production of Cornell
University
alright good morning everybody welcome
to the 6th annual Cornell pioneer
symposium we're very excited that you
are out here both in cornell and geneva
and all across rather if you're on the
webinar my name is Daniel Sweeney and on
behalf of the student organizing
committee for the pioneer symposium and
synapses for graduate student plant
breeding organization we're very excited
to have you here for a seminar today so
this year our theme is C to start up the
startup business mentality is broadly
characterized by small size risk-taking
and innovative thinking and may be
beneficial to plant breeding efforts it
symposium featured speakers addressing
how small plating companies start and
find success in a marketplace dominated
by larger breeding companies a large
breeding companies evaluate acquire and
collaborate with startups and how
researchers start work and largely
unknown and novel crops I'd also like to
acknowledge the gracious support of
dupont pioneer for allowing us to have
it symposium for the sixth year in a row
and also the support of the section of
plant breeding genetics here at Cornell
and synapses the grad student
organization I like to invite Padre
Abadie to give a few opening remarks for
us and then we will commence with the
speakers okay good morning everybody's
and is a pleasure and an honor again to
be here and about 66 symposium on a row
and great great great thing to be back
in in Ithaca it took me some time to get
here this time but I made it and I'm
very glad to be here with you guys and
so I you know as usual to start this I
you know we try to give a little bit of
a reference about what the series is
about and why we do it and you know and
you know a little bit of context of
where we are going around the world too
so see if I can with this one okay sorry
I am a fashion so so the series is is
you know it's a series that that is a
fully student-run the students organized
run absolutely all the logistics and
manage the budget and make all the
decisions around the symposia and the
each of each of the university's work on
on their own in a way and as much as
possible collaborating with the other
universities around the world but
driving their own agenda actually to
actually do what is meaningful for them
both from the scientific or from
educational perspective in in in their
own situation for us we think that this
is a way to meaningful meaningfully
contribute to education because you know
some of the skills that the stewards you
know learn or acquire during the process
our hands-on skills related to you know
due to budget management risk management
making adequate networking in you know
with with the scientific community
communication in general there are all
very very important skills that are
going to be useful for their future
careers and no matter where wait where
they end on on their career and and I
think that that is a major emphasis for
us because the way that we see this is
we are helping to we are we are
contributing to build a broader
scientific community for for the future
and another thing is we think that this
is an opportunity for outreach you know
not only for Pioneer to actually share
what we are doing but for you know for
the whole community to actually open it
up to to the public listen to new ideas
and discuss in a scientific you know
manner you know relevant topics for
the students and the last one of course
is you know while while doing this we we
think that the students are you know
have the opportunity to think about
their future career career opportunities
discuss about that you know that was
probably the topic of my conversation
yesterday with multiple of you that I
had had the chance to talk but and I
think that we try to be very open minded
on that I mean very clearly making it
clear that it is not just about One
career opportunity but its broader we
want to promote that idea generally so a
little bit about the history of the
series we started in Minnesota 10 you
know in 2008 and and we kept doing this
important mending soda continuously and
this year's going to be the tenth and
then consecutive in Minnesota and then
you know this was a great idea and it
worked very well the students as Mark
always says once you ask the shoes to
the gradual to organize something they
do a great job right mark and so you
know we took it to marathon as a proof
of concept to see what's really going to
work and the year after we began
expanding around the world and this is
where we are this year and I left in the
front the flyer that you can see all the
new universities are added the serum
actually I realize now that is not
absolutely complete we have at least one
more University in the series now but
the idea is again you know to build a
global forum and as much as possible to
take this opportunity you know to
everybody that is interested in
participating and playing in a way
within you know the general rules of
this series and so we are excited that
we have reached this level Daniel was
asking me get the world where where when
is it gonna stop and I I don't know okay
and so you know i mean because there are
you know at the idea is become known by
all
people they really want to participate
and have the opportunity to you know to
do this on on their own communities too
so we see so but in in the meantime and
while I have you know energy i will i
would i would try to keep it you know to
give you the opportunity to as many
people that are interested as possible
so you know at the end of the series
this year we we will have more than
night we would have had more than 90
events in i think now is it really
around 42 universities and more than
15,000 participants in general last year
there was an event in india in which the
total number of participants was more
than a thousand and i don't know how
they did it honestly I was not really
there it will do what a way but it was
you know everybody that was there you
know was very excited and it was a great
event for them and a great opportunity
for them to bring people from all around
the subcontinent to so another thing
that we want to do with this is to you
know to build a forum for participation
and you know one thing that we try to do
every year and at least once or twice a
year is took up other on in-person
meeting or you know virtual meeting with
as many participants and organizers as
possible to make general decisions about
the series and which other thing that we
need to keep doing and you know to
establish the general governance of the
series so that you know it doesn't rely
on a single person in a way you know and
we shared the decisions among everybody
on and actually you know that were there
were a lot of ideas that we had that we
tested that we discarded and so it is a
great opportunity for people to think
broadly to about the whole series not
just about their own experience that
they manage very well but actually to
think and to learn from other people
around the world and
and another component I think that it is
very important is the idea of expanding
expanding topics and expanding I opening
up to new ideas and I think that Cornell
has been a testament for that I mean you
always bring new things into into the
table and i am very us they be very very
proud of that you know of the work that
you guys do and but other places are
actually doing the same we started
originally to be sincere around plant
breeding and a little bit of bias on our
side but but we have been expanding
right and we now have symposia that are
you know are mainly based on and on a
much more diverse set of topics right i
mean you know from pure plant pathology
and entomology to genomic engineering
and we are even considering working with
some projects that are working on the
interface between engineering and the
plant sciences so that we could actually
begin working with a broader community
into that space to and bring the idea
and you know i mean expand our
connections for the future of plant
sciences to so big big things are going
to happen in the near future and I hope
that you know we really are able to
expand this even further the other thing
is you know I always put this is this is
an opportunity for communication and
some of the universities have been
publishing about this and publishing in
the academic community is a very
powerful tool right to communicate and
to systematize and to make things clear
on what are your objectives and you know
these are things are all peer-reviewed
so in a way you know it becomes part of
the larger community by participated in
the language and ways of of the
community and the last thing is in each
of the symposia has their own web page
and we
a centralized web page there is it and
if we have a repository of all the web
pages of the individual symposia and
people can actually go to that
centralized web page and you navigate
back to the individual web pages to get
information and in some cases the
webcasts and you know the information
about the speakers organizers and things
like that we are imaginative thinking
about doing some research on all these
data that we have gathered over the gear
I mean I think that we have enough
replication how 9090 event you actually
try to do some data mining and actually
try to understand what has happened and
with that again thank to synapses and
and to the community here in cornell for
for doing this and for keeping keeping
doing this and thank you all for coming
here and i hope that we have a great
event and I'm sure that we will and we
will enjoy a great day thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu